all right joining me now is arkansas
senator tom cotton senator
this uh u.n speech uh running from uh
reporters
today was another disastrous day for
biden on the world stage
but
does that translate into any humility at
home
certainly not from joe biden and the
democrats but you're right laura that
this
speech was a disgrace at the united
nations joe biden walked into the united
nations and slapped a giant kick me sign
on uncle sam's back and in particular as
it relates to china he bent over
backwards to conciliate and appease the
chinese communist party he said we don't
seek a new cold war well china has been
waging a cold war against america and
our workers and our military for decades
so the question is not whether we seek
one the question is whether or not we
will fight back in it yet joe biden
wouldn't even say the word china he's
apparently too scared to even mention
china's name
in a speech addressed to the world's
leaders what kind of signal does that
send to them what kind of signal does it
sing send to the leaders of beijing i
can tell you what they're doing right
now they're laughing at joe biden well
speaking of president xi decides very
smartly you know if for someone who's a
you know gross violator of human rights
he's very clever in adopting the
language of the woke crowd watching
we need to pursue dialogue
and inclusiveness over confrontation
and exclusion
we need to build a new type of
international relations based on mutual
respect
equity
justice and win-win cooperation
what does equity justice and
inclusiveness mean for the uyghurs
taiwan and hong kong
yeah exactly lara so you're talking
about a man in a regime that has crushed
hong kong's autonomy and freedom that is
sterilizing
religious and ethnic minorities in
northwest china or putting them in
gulags has destroyed thousands of
christian churches across china yet he
presumes to lecture us and that's
because joe biden his administration
basically accepts those terms remember
when tony blinken went up for a summit
in alaska and got lectured to or joe
biden's u.n ambassador said that white
supremacy was woven through the origins
of this nation i can tell you it's not
just xi jinping every two bit chinese
diplomat in apparatchik around the world
goes into the foreign ministries of
countries and tells them that they
should not listen to america they should
not lecture china about human rights
because america has its own problems
with human rights and that's all because
of joe biden and his senior cabinet
members accepting those terms of debate
on anti-american grounds senator in
national review today there was a piece
about how it was well done how the
republicans should not rescue the
democrats at this point in the 3.5
trillion uh spending bill reconciliation
bill uh negotiations um do you agree
with that given this big debate also
over the debt ceiling uh and where
that's headed
well laura yeah we're not we're not
going to rescue the democrats in their
efforts to try to implement the largest
tax hike in history and spend six
trillion dollars on things like welfare
and health care for illegal aliens or
welfare for dead beats who won't work or
even look for work
or tax credits for rich people so they
can buy electric cars if the democrats
want to spend six trillion dollars on a
party-line basis then the democrats can
raise the debt ceiling by that much on a
party-line basis to cover their own
reckless socialist agenda
we had 19 republicans agree to that
so-called infrastructure bill which kind
of set this on a bit of a glide path did
it not
well i don't think you're going to see
that many republicans vote for it in the
house next week and right now it looks
like the democrats are in total disarray
not just on that infrastructure bill or
their massive spending blowout but on
the simple act of trying to keep the
government funded next week even though
they control the house the senate and
the white house republicans have
cautioned them for two months now that
we will not help them implement this
reckless six trillion dollar spending
plan by raising the debt ceiling it's
time they took it seriously they funded
the government to keep it open past next
week and that they avoid any kind of
default on our debt next month well
we'll be watching what senator mcconnell
proposes i understand there's some new
ideas in the works senator great to see
you tonight thank you i'm steve ducey
i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis